no pressure that's a good belief system
tony decouple has i say
you're held in high esteem all right cbs
news contributor david becker joins us
now he's an election law expert
and the founder of the center for
election innovation and
research good morning david thanks for
being with us good morning
as we mentioned 94 million people have
uh have already voted
how unprecedented is that and what do
you think it's likely to mean for
turnout tomorrow
well we've never even come close to this
in american history to put this in
perspective
by the time we get to the polls opening
tomorrow there will have been
at least 100 million people who have
already cast their ballots
that means if we see turnout around 150
or 160 million which would be
record turnout by far in american
history and we would
we would see the highest percentage in
really
in american history since we've seen
universal suffrage of eligible voters
but also we'd actually see fewer people
voting on election day than we have in
recent elections
because so many people have already
gotten their ballots in david there's
been a lot of talk about the legitimacy
of this election the president has
raised doubts there are concerns about
foreign interference
is there any any reason to believe that
the u.s won't hold
a free and fair election tomorrow not at
all in fact there's a lot of reason to
believe we're going to hold a very free
and fair and one of the most secure
elections we've ever had
and again one of the key reasons is that
100 million ballots that are already
in the scanners ready to be counted on
election night
if we had had any problems if we had
seen any interference with election
infrastructure it's highly likely we
would have detected it already
there's going to be fewer voters voting
on election day by far
than we're going to have seen voting
over the last several weeks
david the president has also said after
this election one of the first calls
he's making is to his lawyer he has some
issue with ballots being counted after
election day
what do you make of that well i think
it's
uh it's a little troubling to hear those
that kind of language coming from any
candidate particularly an incumbent
president
um look i mean right now the game should
be to try to get as many voters out and
to win the election
with more voters than your opponent
we're not really seeing that from the
president
hopefully that will we'll get a clear
answer from the voters i think the
record
turnout that we are seeing is going to
yield a very clear answer from the
voters and i think there's
a very good chance we're going to know
who the president is sometime very late
tuesday night early wednesday morning
president also says he will declare
victory if he's ahead he seems to have
walked that back a little bit now
but what happens if a candidate declares
victory too early
well canada can do whatever he wants but
um
of course we've had this process for a
long time this has always been the way
it's been
we have never declared a winner on
election night unless the
margins were excessively large it's uh
it's very very normal to allow the
process of counting all the ballots to
go on